[Music]
we congratulate you you got engaged on
Valentine's Day yeah I was thinking
about it for the longest time and I
don't know anything about this
engagement stuff I never thought I was
gonna get engaged but I thought his
Valentine's date she liked cheesy and
she said yes so and she doesn't say
anything about it since then but it all
worked out
no I think well first of all did you did
you pick up on that you did did you
think like I'm gonna do this on
Valentine's Day it'll be more romantic
or did it just work out that it was
Valentine's Day and then you realize he
was you know I planned for it I thought
it would be romantic but then I also
thought I could be that guy the cheesy
guy but it was all right yeah did you do
one of those a little give her like a
little candy that says will you marry me
or that you know anything you know some
people do clever stuff like they tie the
ring to a dog and I don't seriously III
voice think seriously dude yeah people
do that where's my car dude yeah I you
know what I thought about all those
things and then I just I think was like
a just a dinner like yeah and well we
had a guy I got a guy play music before
and I don't I don't remember any it was
in a different language so he could have
been singing something totally different
but not marry this man
yeah it's a disaster did okay now she is
a model is that correct yes she is
dude el fuego of all that is el fuego
the hottest of that
oh dude where's my car reference okay
yeah
she is the fuego of all that is el fuego
Wow so well she's a model what kind of
modeling does she do um
underwear underwear anywhere specialist
a Victoria's Secret model just say it
man don't be sorry I was I was confused
I thought underwear I thought you'd
appreciate the underwear modeling but
yeah Victoria's Secrets yeah I'm
familiar with it yeah it's a very poorly
named product I know I'm just saying
it's you know it's poorly named yeah
everyone is aware of Victoria season it
is a terrible secret the secret is make
should be called Victoria's bad right
exactly Victoria's yesterday's news
bitter guy I'm sorry what is nice
underwear but it's not a secret okay I'm
gonna stay on track here I apologize to
Victoria's Secret I give you thumbs up
see the what I'm curious about is okay
Victoria Secret model I mean your
friends must be secretly I know they
were very respect when everything high
five and you left and right
exactly well you know I told my brother
you know you know I was doing a great
girl and I told her what what she does
and he's like oh no way dude
so say yeah he's like and then I I go we
should go on Google and and which is a
weird thing like I'd never have done
that like check out a girl that I was
dating but she's got some hot photos on
there so my brother was like oh my god
she's so hot and he looked at another
was a no wait no no look at me
you've got to be kidding me and I was
like you know like I love this chick
right he's like oh yeah I'm saying like
a brother like you know is a really
pretty girl